[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Lionel MACETA directeur
du Théâtre de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
scène nationale bonjour bonjour à votre
salle de spectacle se trouve à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux vous êtes en
collaboration avec d'autres salles de
spectacle du territoire pour prévoir des
spectacles hors les murs alors quelles
sont les objectifs à travers ces
spectacles alors les murs alors il y a
deux catégories de spectateurs les murs
il y a le premier c'est les partenariats
que l'on peut avoir avec les autres
salles du territoire notamment celle de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin et puis
il y a les spectacles de des formes
techniquement beaucoup plus légères qui
circulent non seulement dans
l'agglomération mais également dans tout
le le département des Yvelines une
cinquantaine de représentations par
saison qui peut tourner dans les foyers
ruraux dans les centres sociaux etc etc
cette collaboration notamment pour
répondre à votre question avec les avec
les les autres lieux de 50 ans en
Yvelines c'est tout simplement que le
rôle d'une scène nationale c'est de
faire en sorte que il est communication
entre les différentes entre les
différents acteurs culturels et
artistiques du territoire l'idée n'est
pas que chacun travaille dans son coin
mais de savoir comment est-ce qu'on peut
travailler ensemble soutenir les mêmes
artistes voir même en des temps de
raréfaction des financements publics
comment est-ce qu'on peut mutualiser un
certain nombre de un certain nombre de
moyens avec le même objectif qui est de
faire se rencontrer et les artistes et
les publics mais on va s'arrêter sur la
programmation de votre salle de
spectacle on va commencer avec le
spectacle scotch alors c'est du premier
au 3 février alors il nous a un petit
peu plus sur ce spectacle le spectacle
scotch pose la question de savoir
comment est-ce qu'on se débrouille avec
les moyens du bord en fait il s'adresse
aux jeunes enfants et à leur famille là
aussi un point important dans la
programmation que les familles ne
s'ennuient pas quand elles amènent les
jeunes au spectacle les moyens du bord
en l'occurrence et le scotch qui va être
manipulé de maintes façon différente
et qui va montrer que
juste avec de l'imagination et avec très
peu de moyens on peut on peut construire
des mondes des mondes entiers on peut
être actif et c'est aussi ça que l'on
que l'on revendique c'est-à-dire que
face à la passivité
la passivité que l'on peut avoir devant
des écrans quels qu'ils soient
avec les moyens du bord bien sans les
écrans on est obligé d'être beaucoup
plus actif et beaucoup plus imaginatif
et nous on revendique la place de
l'imagination c'est notre travail et
c'est un spectacle des deux ans donc
avoir avoir en famille du 7 au 11
février le spectacle la tendresse ce
questionnera sur la masculinité autour
de cette question qu'est-ce qu'être un
mec aujourd'hui alors mais qu'est-ce qui
attend le public justement lors de ces
représentations on va pas nier le fait
que nous soyons d'une société plutôt
patriarcale ou les rôles sont assignés
c'est-à-dire que les caractéristiques on
va dire que l'homme est fort la femme
est fragile l'homme est enclin la
violence la femme est plutôt empreinte
de douceur etc aujourd'hui ce modèle
bien heureusement est en train d'être
questionné voir peut-être d'exploser et
la question que se pose les 8 ou qui est
posé au 8 interprètes qui sont à la fois
danseurs comédien qui sont absolument
extraordinaires c'est comment vous
jeunes gens vous vous dépatouillez de
toutes ces de toutes ces questions et de
l'explosion dans du modèle patriarcal
c'est vraiment un spectacle qui est fait
pour
les gens qui qui enfin je trouve qu'il
est absolument formidable pour les gens
qui ne vont pas au théâtre et qui se
font une fausse idée du théâtre parce
que on rit on pleure sans jamais perdre
de vue le sujet qui est comment est-ce
que vous vous dépatouillez de ces
nouvelles Décines de ces nouvelles
questions donc amnésie tous les gens qui
ne sont pas habitués à aller au théâtre
parce que c'est un moment extraordinaire
alors justement pour vous le théâtre
doit avoir ce rôle de de ce questionner
de questionner le public et pourquoi pas
d'apporter des des réponses ben il a
plusieurs certainement pas d'apporter
des réponses parce que ça je pense que
les publics des spectateurs sont assez
grands pour eux-mêmes apporter des
réponses et je pense même que dans la
programmation on est à l'inverse de ça
c'est à dire que
on va pas dire qu'on est contre le
militantisme mais on est dans une autre
forme de militantisme qui est en
parlez-vous de ces questions et
répondez-y vous-même donc le théâtre et
là bien entendu pour donner une autre
vision
une vision décalée du monde dans lequel
on vit et aussi effectivement là pour
pour nous poser des questions en
regardant différemment on voit et on
comprend les choses différemment donc on
est là pour ça entre autres et pour se
donner une petite idée on va écouter un
extrait justement du teaser et on
poursuit juste après à chaque fois que
je
j'ai ce rêve d'un amour qui défile le
temps ouais on vieillit ensemble il y a
pas de trahison j'ai peur d'être déçu
je me demande est-ce que grandir
c'est passé son temps à perdre des gens
je sais pas si je suis quelqu'un dans
ton souverain je suis quelqu'un de très
enfin je suis pas typique je suis assez
banal je crois
un autre âge c'est trop la pression
pour réussir réussir tu penses qu'à ça
je lui dis les va prochaines années de
ma vie j'ai une pile de livres et je
fais que ça j'apprends ma vie c'est une
succession de moments où je me suis dit
là c'est fini
je me relèverai pas alors tu tiens par
la colère tu te dis je vais tout brûlé
moi y compris tu as l'impression que tu
respires dans le feu avec des années je
me suis fait la tendresse donc du 7 au
11 février le 9 février il y a une
rencontre qui est prévue avec Julie
Perez donc la mété la metteur en scène
et l'équipe artistique du spectacle
alors pourquoi organiser une rencontre
autour de ce spectacle
ce spectacle plus spécifiquement
nécessite une rencontre et va forcément
va forcément donner lieu à un débat non
mais c'est la rencontre avec les
artistes c'est tout simplement pour des
échanges de point de vue je pense qu'il
y a des choses que les artistes doivent
doivent entendre il y a des choses que
les publics peuvent entendre aussi quels
sont les intentions de la méthode en
scène quels sont les intentions des
artistes qui sont sur scène voilà c'est
c'est un échange il me semble important
de casser ce qu'on appelle le 4ème mur
celui qui sépare les artistes du public
c'est la fin de la représentation on est
tous ensemble et puis on échange sur ce
que l'on a vu il y a rien de pire que de
sortir d'un spectacle et de passer tout
de suite à autre chose je pense doit
aussi infuser et les questions doivent
doivent rester encore quelques temps
après la fin du spectacle et alors on
continue la programmation avec le
spectacle frais frame by frame le le
frame image par image mon accent anglais
est nul c'est le 10 février alors
qu'est-ce qui attend le public justement
pour cette soirée alors frame by frame
par l'Orchestre National de Jazz c'est
un une sorte d'hommage au rock
progressif alors vous êtes Jessie trop
jeune pour avoir connu l'Europe
progressive mais grosso modo le rock
progressif c'est la fin des années 60 le
début des années 70 avec des groupes
emblématiques comme Pink Floyd poste
site Barrett King Crimson ou bien
Genesis et Genesis première période
quand il faisait une musique
intéressante Frédéric Morin le directeur
de l'Orchestre National de Jazz a
demandé à quatre compositrices de
travailler à partir de de morceaux assez
emblématiques de cette époque et qui ont
été composés par ces par ces groupes là
que je vous conseille absolument
d'écouter toute la production entre 1969
et 1972 sont absolument formidables et
elles vont elles vont voilà elles vont
travailler à partir de à partir des
thèmes musicaux de ces de ces de ces
artistes là et créer autre chose c'est à
dire que des morceaux qui font 10
minutes elles vont peut-être les porter
à 15 20 30 minutes donc voilà c'est un
hommage au rock progressif et le 14
février pardon c'est un petit peu de
musique avec somewhere alors quels sont
les objectifs justement de de ce concert
c'est de faire découvrir ou redécouvrir
des des compositeurs américains alors il
y en a qui sont assez connus du grand
public je pense à
Guerche à George Gershwin qui a composé
aussi bien
pour le jazz que pour la musique la
grande musique classique américaine je
pense également Léonard Bernstein dont
on va entendre la version remarquable de
West Side Story pour deux pianos et donc
4mins par Sania et et
il y a aussi des compositeurs qui sont
peut-être un peu moins connus du grand
public comme notamment Copland voilà et
puis en décembre un tout petit peu dans
le sud des États-Unis au sud des
États-Unis même jusqu'en Argentine en
restera sur le continent avec des des
œuvres de Astor Piazzolla et du 15 au 18
février le spectacle pister les
créatures fabuleuses sera présentée au
Théâtre de 50 ans en Yvelines une
rencontre est également prévu un le 16
février avec l'équipe du spectacle que
va raconter la pièce alors on peut
penser que pour voir des choses
fabuleuses des créatures fabuleuses il
faut voyager très très loin de là où là
où nous vivons et ce que nous dit ce
spectacle c'est que il suffit d'ouvrir
les yeux sur ce que l'on a autour de
nous qu'il s'agisse des gens qui
s'agissent de la nature qu'il s'agisse
de l'EN environnement pour se rendre
compte que le fabuleux est vraiment à
portée de main et et voilà peut-être
nous sommes nous pas assez attentifs à
notre environnement quotidien donc là
c'est une incitation à ouvrir les yeux
sur l'environnement dans lequel nous
vivons au quotidien et donc c'est du 15
au 18 février avec je le rappelle donc
une
rencontre du coup le 16 février donc
pareil pour pour pouvoir parler un petit
peu de de tout ça merci beaucoup Lionel
messietta pardon d'avoir été avec nous
sur sensation donc je rappelle que vous
êtes le directeur du Théâtre de 50 ans
en Yvelines scène nationale on peut
retrouver toute la programmation sur
votre site théâtre
sqy.org ou sur notre site internet radio
sensation et pour revoir ou réécouter
cette émission rendez-vous sur notre
site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]